this is what life has become in mariopol
an existence punctuated by the sound of
russian planes and shelling and by fear
and grief
people hoping it won't be them next
we have no information at all we know
nothing it's as if we are living in a
dark forest
russian forces continue to attack the
southern ukrainian port city more than
four hundred thousand people are trapped
in what the mayor calls an apocalypse
water and electricity supplies are cut
food and medicine scarce some people
managed to evacuate on monday but not
very many
in a makeshift hospital in the city a
baby girl is born into a world her
mother could never have imagined
moments that should be filled only with
joy are overshadowed by fear
she survived after maternity hospital
number three was bombed and ruined she
was brought here all birthing mothers
have lived through so many things
maternity hospital number three was
destroyed by russian shelling on
wednesday mariana also survived she's
named her baby veronica
uh
we were lying in wards when glass frames
windows and walls flew apart we don't
know how it happened we were in our
wards and some had time to cover
themselves and some didn't
emergency workers had rescued this woman
after the attack but doctors were unable
to save her or her baby
in the eastern city of kramertorsk
people are picking through what's left
of their homes
a fourth round of talks between russian
and ukrainian negotiators was paused but
is set to resume on tuesday meanwhile
ukraine's president issued a warning to
western powers on monday after a russian
attack near nato member poland's border
and now i repeat again if you do not
close the skies it's only a matter of
time before russian missiles fall on
your territory on nato territory
on the homes and citizens of nato
countries
russian forces continue to target
western parts of the country this tv
tower in the city of rivene was hit by
missiles
and in the city of lev another night of
air sirens ended bringing another day of
uncertainty
since the beginning of the invasion la
viva has been considered as something of
a safe haven but with a growing number
of attacks in western ukraine some
people here are really starting to feel
that the war is closing in people in the
city are preparing for the worst
today we completely didn't have any
safety
location or region in our country and so
it was predictable because when the
first time see that russian troops
killed on the main streets of kharkiv
marupo
children they bombed children's
hospitals so they can use everything
yura says leviv feels safer than his
home city of kiev for now but he knows
that could change
i don't understand what happened in this
world
three weeks ago russian army attacks our
cities our
peoples our children
and they don't understand how brother
can go to another brother and kill him i
don't understand
across ukraine people have no choice
than to put one foot in front of the
other to keep living despite the chaos
and cruelty of war clinging on to the
hope that tomorrow could be different
natasha butler al jazeera live western
ukraine